today I'm going to give you a quick
rundown of everything you need to know
before you see Ekko the new Marvel
series set to hit Disney plus and Hulu
on January 10th 2024 don't worry this
video is spoiler-free so you can watch
it without ruining any surprises from
the series but there will be mentions
from other MCU titles now it's time to
know before you
go first of all who is Ekko Ekko was
created by David Mack and Joe CA in 1999
and she first appeared in Daredevil
number 91 she's the adoptive daughter of
Wilson Fisk AKA The Kingpin who of the
most notorious Crim Lords in the Marvel
Universe Fisk raised Ekko after he
killed her father Willie Crazy Horse
Lincoln who was the leader of the
tracksuit Mafia a gang of Russian Thugs
who wear matching tracksuits FIS lied to
Ekko and told her that Daredevil was the
one who killed her father and he trained
her to become a skilled fighter and
assassin he also gave her the code name
echko because of her ability to mimic
anyone's actions and the comics echko
has a condition called photographic
reflexes which means she can learn any
skill or technique just by watching it
once she can fight like Daredevil shoot
like Hawkeye play the piano like Mozart
and even speak sign language she's also
a talented artist and a college graduate
however she's not a superhero and
doesn't have any real superpowers she's
just a human being who has honed her
natural gifts to the fullest ekko's
first encounter with Daredevil was in
the comics where she was sent by Fisk to
seduce Matt Murdoch Daredevil's alter
ego and then kill him however she fell
in love with Murdoch and she eventually
learned the truth about Fisk and her
father's death she confronted Fisk and
shot him in the eye blinding him she
then left New York and went on a journey
of self-discovery where she met other
Heroes like Wolverine Spider-Man and The
Avengers she also took on the identity
of ronin a masked vigilante who uses
various weapons in martial arts she
joined the new Avengers and fought
against the scroll Invasion the dark
Avengers and the Hand a ninja clan that
worships a demon in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Echo made her debut in the
series Hawkeye starring Jeremy rener as
Clint Barton and Haley Steinfeld as Kate
Bishop Ekko was played by alaka Cox a
deaf Native American actress who is also
an amputee in the series Ekko was the
leader of the track suit Mafia who were
after Ronan suit which was worn by Kate
Bishop in a charity auction Ekko had a
personal Vendetta against Ronan who was
actually Clint Barton in Disguise
because he killed her father and many of
her gang members during the blip Ekko
also worked for the Kingpin who was
played by Vincent denafo reprising his
role from the Daredevil Netflix series
The Kingpin was the one who ordered
Ronan to kill ekko's father and he also
manipulated Ekko into thinking that he
cared for her in the final episode of
Hawkeye Ekko confronted Ronan in a
warehouse where he revealed his true
identity and told her the truth about
Kingpin and her father Ekko was shocked
and angry and she decided to leave the
tracksuit Mafia and seek revenge on the
Kingpin Ekko then went to confront the
Kingpin and shot him in the eye just
like in the comics in the trailer for
the series though we saw Vincent denafo
wearing an eye patch hinting that the
Kingpin likely survived this encounter
just like he did in the comics as well
so we can expect to see him and some
other familiar faces later in the series
so what else can we expect from the echo
series well from the official synopsis
the series will follow Echo as she
returns to her hometown in Oklahoma
where she must face her past reconnect
with her Native American roots and
embrace her family and Community the
series will also explore ekko's origin
story and how she became the person she
is today the series will be directed by
Sydney Freeland and catriona McKenzie
who are both Native American filmmakers
and it will be written by Mar and d and
Amy rarden who are both women of color
the series will also have some familiar
faces from the MCU such as Vincent
denafo as the Kingpin Charlie Cox as
Daredevil and Zan McLaren as William
Lopez ekko's father but we should be
careful about getting attached to too
many characters as director Sydney
Freeland said about the show people on
our show they bleed they die they get
killed and there are real world
consequences Ekko will be the first
Marvel series to debut on both Disney
plus and Hulu and it'll also be the
first MCU series to receive a tvma
rating which means that it'll be more
violent and mature than other Marvel
shows the approach is reminiscent of
that of earlier Marvel series like
Daredevil Jessica Jones and Luke Cage
which were more explicit and also rated
tvma it's a little on the grittier side
for Marvel and shows the breath of what
Marvel is capable of said Brad wibom
Marvel Studios head of streaming
television and animation it's sort of a
new direction for the brand especially
for Disney plus the series will also be
part of phase five of the MCU and the
first series under the Marvel Spotlight
Banner which is a new subcategory of
Marvel that will focus on Standalone
stories that are not directly connected
to the main MCU storyline the series
will consist of five episodes and it
will be released in its entirety on
January 10th 2024 and there you have it
everything you need to know before you
see Marble's Echo if you're a fan of the
MCU or you're curious about how things
will play out following Hawkeye you
definitely don't want to miss this show
don't forget to like And subscribe or
check out the video on your screen for
some more of my
[Music]
content